all right going back with Jason Derulo
and Nicole Byer
and we're helping Emily who says she's
unlucky in love and finds all the wrong
prospects online well today things are
gonna change we're trying a new approach
with Emily all right she's borrowing my
chair from The Voice to pick her next
man she'll have no idea what the guys
look like because this chair forces you
to listen this is blind dating all right
let's meet the guys hi everybody my name
is Tim hi Emily I come from a small farm
town called Elmont Michigan but I live
out here in Los Angeles as a independent
filmmaker awesome hi I'm Ellie I'm Nick
from Miami Florida I speak five
languages French Portuguese oh my gosh
German blacker so here's how this is
gonna go Tim and Nick will take turns
talking just like in the voice if Emily
hears something she likes she'll hit the
button the chair will turn and that will
be the man she chooses while she can hit
the button at any time it doesn't mean
she should this works better with just a
little patience let's get started Tim
and Nick what is your idea of a perfect
date well my idea of a perfect date
actually involves the happiest place on
earth and Disneyland
I think you get to know a lot about a
person by their favorite character and
also what rides they choose so we would
start off the day by walking down Main
Street maybe sharing a chi rose some ice
cream maybe and then we would have a
reservation for two at one of their
five-star restaurants and then finish
off the evening with a beautiful
fireworks show at Cinderella's castle
Almighty knows what happened in there
all right Peter what do you guys think
no no that's too magical the second date
is what in a dumpster I know but I also
felt like the answer was a little like
let me give her what she wants no no I
will tell you this I read things that
were gonna say before they got here
he actually had that in his thing
important actually that was not because
all right so what's your perfect date
well I would be taking you to the second
happiest place on earth
Runyon Canyon we'd go hiking because I'm
very adventurous and we go up to the top
right get to know each a little bit see
the sunset watch the LA lights and I'll
take you to my favorite Michelin star
restaurant honey
that's spending the whole day together
what do you think on the first date you
can't get to know me well huffing and
puffing yeah you know what that you know
what I like about it if you like me
sweaty and gross then you're in you know
yeah I like that one I like I like that
all right what you like working out yeah
well great job guys you haven't hit the
button Emily good yeah you're okay okay
good let's ring it things up okay you
know I believe in the magic of song and
this is my voice chair so I just wanna
embarrass these men I asked Tim and Nick
to pin their very own love ballads all
right guys it's all on you Emily you hit
the button if you feel it but maybe
listen to both songs okay
okay Emily here we go for a little
country in you for a little bit baby
don't be scared cuz I'm scared too
I know love has burned you a time or two
and all that I ask is for a single
chance to show you how love really feels
alright alright okay that was cute I was
really good I liked the country I liked
the soul in it
Oh check this out so you're looking for
love on Kandi's show love to be a Latino
you get to know the trust me when I say
penis I see ya learn some Spanish I love
the teacher I didn't really feel the
heart
it can be so blind but with your hand in
mine I know everything will be just fine
and your backs turned to me girl it's
harder to see that beautiful smile I
seen
[Applause]
I think I know what it was it was
Disneyland in China
it always does yeah alright so Emily
what made you choose him over the other
guy I would say obviously the Disneyland
got me you really knew all the parts of
the parks and that's always encouraging
the churro I like churros and the
country twang I could sense a Midwest
southern feel yeah that's my I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this